you should see the places they play in
the soviet union i'm planning on it
you have to get past me first i'm
planning on that too
did netflix make the perfect movie by
giving it subscribers the queen's gambit
or should they be calling defeat netflix
subscribers have been raving about the
streaming service's newest hit original
that's putting a whole new face to the
dark and twisted world of professional
chess
and if you've already taken the seven
episode plunge you've probably realized
that you stumbled across
one of the most well-crafted shows the
platform has
ever seen but what about this chess
series has the creators screaming
checkmate
and audience members crying tears of joy
was the show's ending satisfying or did
beth harmon's powerful feminist edge
distract you
from the possible meaning behind the
finale in this video
we'll be walking you through everything
you need to know and
might have missed about the series
shedding some light on the show's finale
and looking at what exactly a potential
season 2 of the queen's gambit could
look like
just know that if you found yourself
crying at the end of the very emotional
finale
you're not alone just a fair warning
before we really get into it there will
be spoilers for season one of the
queen's gambit in this video
so tread lightly it's your game
like many iconic series and movies the
queen's gambit is based on a novel
written by walter tevis
and while the book and series are
fictional chess buffs will quickly
realize that a lot of the figures and
events that happen throughout the story
are loosely based on the chess world of
the 1950s and 60s
despite it all you don't need to know
anything really about how the game works
to enjoy the show's wild ride
in fact the main actress anya taylor joy
knew absolutely nothing when she was
offered the part of beth harmon
all she knew was she had to bring her to
life and almost immediately knew
it wasn't all about chess ah now i'm
like really messed up it's like no this
is a very serious disease
and there's a reason for all of it so
who exactly is beth harmon
and why is she so captivating when you
get to the end of the series you realize
that beth is the perfect
advocate for a strong independent woman
she makes sure she's no one's pawn in
both the political and
religious world fine
i'll give it all back i hope you know
what you're doing dear
and the fluidity when it comes to her
love life especially the night she
spends with supermodel cleo
is groundbreaking considering the time
period the series takes place in
she doesn't care period she is her
own person albeit with some deep deep
emotional issues
but from the beginning to the end she
refuses to submit to anyone
netflix gave us an epic character that
stood on her own
without the overused storyline of
depending on male companions
especially in the 1950s i will win them
no harmon you won't need to play seismo
or goldman first
you can't be either of them but let's
take a closer look at her entire journey
to her self-love
she's quiet she's shy and in the
traditional sense
beth starts out as a pretty bland
nine-year-old orphan but the more
tragedy we learn about her life
the more we start to realize that she
has all the qualities to make up a
pretty epic tale of the hero's journey
we've all seen the same hero story play
out in movies like the hunger games
katniss leaves home to overcome her
oppression and find who she is
and the same thing happens in films like
harry potter and the lord of the rings
beth has the baggage of her mother's
death and her early addiction to
substances
her escape is her unique talent for
chess but what sets her apart from other
hypothetical heroes is that her battles
stick with her basically throughout the
entire series
despite her talent even when she's going
on to become more of a professional
chess player
she's haunted by her substance addiction
it literally follows her no matter the
environment
i felt like a fool i knew that feeling
helpless
the tragedy doesn't stop she then loses
her adoptive mother to hepatitis
in fact the only constant person or
country that seems to always be present
is vasily borgov the russian chess
player we were introduced to from the
very beginning
and the whole time i'd look at his face
and there was no doubt and the finale is
all about that
but before she can fully win against him
she has to return home
things come full circle for beth when
she spaced with the orphanage her
younger self suffered in
and when she finally decided to flush
her tranquilizers down the toilet
is when she's finally able to take
charge of her own life
her friends are brought back into her
life including towns
someone she's always had a strong
connection to and she's finally able to
travel to russia
to beat borgov it's a big deal
beating the soviets at the wrong game
the series ends with beth
arguably being the most well-known chess
player in the world
in the final shot beth leaves her car
headed for a flight back to america
to join a group of old men playing chess
in a park on the surface the finale
isn't that emotional but if you've spent
the seven episodes invested in beth's
journey like we were
crying at the end of the finale was
probably cathartic
[Music]
thinking about just what beth went
through from being the nine-year-old
orphan addicted to tranquilizers to the
messy and tragic life she led in order
to get to where she is at the end
well to put it simply it was a ride a
very steep
emotional roller coaster and i think
that maybe on some level we can all
relate to beth's journey
maybe not during her drastic life
milestones but in the way we still
fight for our independence today if
you're still questioning why crying at
the end of the finale just didn't make
sense
anya also couldn't help her tears from
falling after filming beth's spinal
scene
but like us it was tears of joy she told
refinery29
every time we finished that sequence i
would just burst into tears
because i was so happy for her she has
found this sense of contentment
where she wasn't in pain or fighting
something so intensely
but no matter how cathartic the ending
was was this the finale beth wanted
or was it the finale the world she lived
in wanted
we're going to say a little bit of both
now will you please
promise to print that absolutely thank
you yes yes
sure she met the high pressures and
expectations that were put on her from
the moment her talent was discovered
but at the same time she overcame those
expectations
while taking back the control over her
life that had been missing since the
accident that killed her birth mom
there was also speculation that the
final scene meant beth was leaving her
life in america behind
and staying in the ussr but anya put
that to rest by saying
nope she called the scene of beth
playing chess with the old men
her victory lap a second in time to
finally be normal
the queen's gambit has been a long time
coming bringing this story to life
wasn't a decision made on a whim
co-creator alan scott admitted he's been
trying to bring it to life since the 90s
and a movie was set to be made in 2008
with heath ledger making his directorial
debut
but we all unfortunately know that heath
passed away from an accidental overdose
before that could be made possible
but his influence on alan scott could be
the reason why beth's battle with
addiction was brought to life so
beautifully and accurately
wow thanks
you're welcome while heath's original
vision was never made
the series has been praised by both tv
critics and chess critics
since its release and has made it to the
top trending spot on netflix
we also can't forget that it earned a
whopping 100
on rotten tomatoes a platform that's
usually brutally honest with their
review
so the next logical step for such a
successful show would be season two
right
not exactly there's been no news on
continuing the series and the show is
considered
a limited miniseries but nothing is off
the table yet
the show ended in a way that makes
season 2 both possible
and not possible so what do you think
will happen
what we do know is that netflix has a
controversial past of cancelling beloved
shows like the oa
and one day at a time before they can
see another season
so will that come into play with the
queen's gambit we also have to ask the
question of whether or not season 2
can keep the spark of feminism and
female independence we saw with beth
throughout the first seven episodes
beth's story was truly wrapped up
perfectly red bow and all
but we also know how complex her
character can be will touching her
character and her development take away
from
everything she went through in season
one we'll have to wait and see
but for right now i think it's time for
a re-watch how about you
will you be tuning in to a possible
season 2 of the queen's gambit
do you think they'll be able to keep
themes like feminism and fluidity that
made the show
so unique in the first place let's
discuss in the comments section below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a like to
keep up with all things the things